I'm John Coleman and I am an assistant scout master with troop number 56 in
Coyerville, Tennessee. This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by
backers like me And now the old scout master.
So the wise old scouter was speaking to a scout who just couldn't fall asleep,
was really having a problem when they were out camping, and he said: well, you
know what I do, I just listened to the symphony, the sweet lullaby of the wild,
and I drift off to sleep. and the scout looks at him and says: well, I'll give it a
try, but those stupid crickets are so loud I really can't hear anything else.
Hey, this is podcast number 263..
Hey, welcome back to the Scout Master podcast. This is Clark Green. We're gonna take a look at the mailbag here. We heard from Matt Hickman who wrote with this little story. He says
I was driving along in the car with my Cub Scout and my Boy Scout sons and I was
talking about scouts and I asked the Cub Scout if he would join the troop if I
signed up to be a leader. and my Boy Scout son corrected me with no
hesitation. He said: you're crazy, dad, you can't be a leader of the troop, you're an adult.
And Matt said. that's right. your senior patrol leader is in charge of the troop.
From the perspective of a second-class scout, the patrol method is working
Well. thanks for that, Matt. That's a great story. Dave LaVenter is the scout master
of troop 301 in Temecula, California, and he wrote in to say in 2013: I emailed you
about my son's experiences as a Weeblos visiting local Boy Scouts troops. You read it on your podcast
and made a blog post out of it, and I will have a link to that blog post from 2013 that Dave
mentions here. There'll be a link in the post that contains this podcast,
But Dave goes on to say what's been going on since. Well, in the two years since my older son
crossed over into the Boy Scouts, he's become a life scout and assistant senior patrol leader.
My younger son was a bear back then and now he's a scout in the same troop.
When the other Weeblos- two parents- asked me about troops, I knew that once they visited
our troop, our scouts would sell the Weeblos on the idea of joining our troop themselves,
And I was right. Our pack has three Weeblos dens and nearly a hundred percent crossed over into the
troop. Add to that another six or so scouts that crossed over from other packs. Our troop
maintains the fun, inclusive environment that attracted us to it in the first place,
and the scouts in the troop are naturally like this. I became a scout master right after the
crossover last month. It's an honor, It's a privilege and I'm told it will only take an hour
a week. Well, thanks for that, Dave. Yeah, I remember hearing from you in 2013..
It's great to hear things are still going well. and let me note this, though:
You say that the scouts in your troop are just naturally inclusive and and
considerate of the younger scouts and things like that. Well, I agree to a point, but I don't
think any scouts are naturally like that. I think scouts are led in that direction
and reflect the kind of culture of the unit, and that starts with the adults who are involved.
So, good on you. Good on you for being a scout master. Once you've listened to the podcast,
you can take 20 minutes or so off of your hour a week and use that time that's left to do your
scout master stuff, And if you need more time, let me know, okay?
Hey, we heard from Craig Dixon, who is with a troop- 682 in Poe, California. He said I just
became a backer. Thank you, Craig. I'm an Eagle Scout from 1980 and I've been a scouter now for
11 years and for that whole time I've used the web as a resource, with mixed results. but your
philosophy of scouting mirrors my experience in scouting as a youth and what I'm trying to
achieve with my troop. I miss the live chats that you have because I'm not on Facebook so I don't get
the notification, and they're also awfully early here on the left coast. Well, let's talk about that
for a moment. Craig, I want to fix both of those things. Usually, I'm having the live chats
on a weekday morning and I know the the west coast is going to be just getting up and getting
going for the day probably, as we're closing the chat down here around 11- 11- 30 and since you're
not on Facebook, you're not getting the notifications. so let's fix both of those things, okay. First of all,
if you'll get in touch with me and you're on the left coast and you want to participate in a chat,
well, I'll figure out how to schedule one in the afternoon or the evening. and secondly, go to the
post that contains this podcast and you'll see where you can sign up to get a text message
when I have a live chat. This is kind of like a beta idea, okay, so let's, let's give it a try.
What you'll do is you'll follow a link and you'll sign up with a with a service that I'm using,
and you'll make sure to put your cell phone number and your profile on that service. I will send you
a text whenever I'm going to have a live chat and that's the only time I will send you a text,
okay, and your number naturally doesn't go to anybody else or anything like that, But that's
in a link in the post that contains this podcast. if you're interested in that, that's good. if
you're on the west coast and you want additional live chat time, let me know. get in touch with
me at Clark at scoutmastercgcom and we'll sort it out. and on the live chat, this week we had a lot
of our old friends, our good old frequent fliers, join in. we also heard from Jay Cohen in New Hampshire,
who's an assistant scout master with Troop 22, and Julio from Bogota, Columbia, signed on,
and we had a great chat with Julio too. so keep an eye on the Facebook and the Twitter feeds
and, like I said, if you want a text announcement, go ahead and check out the service that I'm
using like, and it's, once again, it's just a beta idea, so we'll give it a shot, see how it goes.
Before I continue, let me say this: if the resources that I've created at scoutmastercgcom have helped
you, I need you to help me out in return, because what the idea is is to keep all these resources
coming and keep them freely available to scouts all over the world, just like you.
So go to scoutmastercgcom today, click on the support link at the top of the page
and you'll learn exactly how this works. what'll happen is you'll become a backer, and that means
you'll make one-time voluntary kind of subscription payment, and there are some levels of support
that even get premiums, like autographed copies of my books. so, once again, go to scoutmastercgcom,
click the support link at the top of the page and become a backer, and I want to thank
Mac Barron and Craig Dixon and Brian Earler, who have all become backers since our last podcast.
become a backer this week at scoutmastercgcom and I'll be sure to thank you personally during
our next podcast. Well, in the remainder of this podcast, we got some e-mail questions to answer,
and that's going to do it for this week. so let's get started, shall we?
The cat came back the very next morning. yet the cat came back the very next day. the cat came back.
they thought it wasn't gonna, but the cat came back. it just couldn't stay away.
away,
away.
email that is folks. and here's an answer to one of your emails.
Ron Troson is the scoutmaster of Troop 381 in Howell, Michigan, and Ron wrote in to say: I love
the podcast. you inspired me to stop doing things because of that kind of tribal knowledge
and that's the way we've always done it. reasoning for an Eagle Scout who's been
involved for 30 plus years in scouting, that means kind of a lot of untraining.
so I have this question for you. in the guide to safe scouting I read: depending on the event
or planned activity, it may be required that at least two adults or youth-
though three or four more is preferable- in each touring group have current training
in wilderness first aid and CPR, know how and when to put this knowledge to use
and thoroughly understand the limitation of their knowledge. so Ron is asking, since it says,
depending on the event or activity planned, it may be required, who's going to make the
decision that it is actually required? on the tour plan form it states that wilderness first aid is
recommended for all backcountry tours. so how do we know if it's actually required of us? because
we have a backcountry trip planned and before I'm asking all of our adult leaders to spend the
money and the time to get wilderness first aid trained, I want to make sure it's absolutely
required now. we value first aid training in our adults attend CPR training- but not necessarily
wilderness first aid. well, Ron, uh, first of all, thanks for listening to the podcast and I'm
glad you're enjoying it and getting untrained, hopefully in the very best possible sense of
that idea. now, the key to an answer for your question are terms like highly recommended
and required. okay, the, the bsa, is almost always consistent with what is absolutely required and
what is not, and their language that they use in policies and procedures usually reflects this.
now, wilderness first aid, as you've discovered in the guide to safe scouting, is not absolutely required.
it may be, but the guide to safe scouting doesn't really tell you when exactly it's going to be
required. the only instance that I have found where it's absolutely required is when you're
attending one of the bsa national high adventure bases. if you're doing your own backcountry trip
or your own high adventure outside of one of those bases, then it looks to me like wilderness first aid
is highly recommended. now, if it was absolutely required, you'd be asked to provide certification
when you file a tour plan. and, like you said on the tour plan, wilderness first aid is recommended
but not required for all backcountry tours. I think we've kind of untangled the policy statements right.
so what about wilderness first aid? is it worth getting everybody certified and wilderness
first aid if you're going on an extended backcountry trip? well, my answer is probably okay.
you know, I would think you get as many people certified as is practicable and then you make
sure the people who are certified share their knowledge with everybody else. if you go to
a wilderness first aid course, you're going to learn advanced diagnostic and stabilization techniques for
injuries or illnesses when emergency response is going to be delayed. I mean, this is not rocket
science. okay, it's very, very useful information, but you're not intubating people or stitching
up wounds or trying to maintain somebody for you know, three or four days or something like that
or doing anything, anything really beyond basic first aid. wilderness first aid is highly defined
diagnostic method and, of course, to notify emergency services and help facilitate getting a sick or
injured person out. the American Red Cross has published two things I think you'll find useful
and it kind of give you a jumpstart on this. this is not to substitute for wilderness first aid
training, but if you're interested to get an idea of exactly what's going to happen in wilderness
first aid training, the Red Cross has a pocket guide to wilderness first aid and a reference guide to
wilderness first aid. both our pdf documents and both I will have linked in the post that contain
this podcast. so this has been a little complicated. let's just go back and look over exactly what
we're talking about. the bsa highly recommends wilderness first aid for backcountry trips.
to my knowledge, it is only absolutely required if you're attending a national high adventure
base. that's as best I can tell. so from a policy standpoint, not absolutely required. from common sense
standpoint I would say yes, absolutely. go get wilderness first aid certified if you're going
to do backcountry trips. it takes a little time and a little money to do, but it's it's time and
money well spent and naturally, if you're doing a long backcountry trip, you will have all of your
scouts and scouters trained in the applicable skills like safety afloat and safe swim, defense
and hike on safely and weather hazards and all of that and a lot of that training is available online.
I had this question from a reader and a listener. I understand the importance of the class a and
class b uniforms. when we have to wear heavier clothing because of the weather, nobody can see
our uniforms. so I suggested that we get sweatshirts or something like that with our troop number
or logo on them, and the reply I got back was that this would not be an official part of
the uniform, so we're not going to get them. so my question is: is it possible to purchase sweatshirts
with our logo even though it's not an official scout uniform? well, the short answer is yes and
the longer answer is: there's a number of really persistent urban legends and all kinds of other
things that happen around uniforms and the wearing of patches. so let me- let me just take the time
to see if we can unwind a couple of those. first of all, there's no class a or class b
uniform. it's a common scouting reference. people use it all the time, but you won't find it in any
official scouting resources, at least none that I have seen. if you do, let me know. there's only the
uniform, and exactly what that is is laid out in the uniform inspection sheets, and I'll have a link
to those in the post that contains this podcast. the second legend is: is that uniforms are ever
required by national policy? they're not. if you go to the guide to awards and insignia-
again, I'll have a link to it in the post that contains this podcast- you'll find this statement:
while wearing the uniform is not mandatory is not mandatory, it is highly encouraged. the leaders
of scouting, both volunteer and professional, promote the wearing of the correct and complete uniform
on all suitable occasions. now when folks start arguing about uniforms and the placement of
patches, I'm reminded of something that Baden Powell once wrote: it is almost beyond belief that
grown up- or nearly grown up- men can take little matters so seriously and so narrowly as some do.
so if there's some kind of friction being created around uniforms, we can- you can usually
resolve those arguments pretty quickly by referencing the uniform inspection sheets
and taking a look in the guide to awards and insignia. if it's not there, it's not a policy.
okay, it's very, very simple. now, if you want visibility while you're out working on projects or camping,
wearing a troop sweatshirt or a t-shirt is certainly not restricted in anything. I've read,
with very, very few exceptions. I don't dictate what my scouts wear, so long as what they're
wearing is appropriate to the activity, and those exceptions are usually because somebody else
has created a rule where they have to wear a uniform when we go to summer camp or something like that.
now, of course, I promote and encourage the wearing of the correct complete uniform and I wear it
myself on all suitable occasions, but that's a choice each individual scout makes for themselves
and I really end up taking little notice of what they choose to do. in that regard,
Jim Boggs wrote in to say I am already the scout master for a troop that's a little over a
year old now, and I've just became the committee chair for our newly formed crew. while I understand
and struggle to keep the patrol method going in the troop, I am wondering how crews are organized.
the only reference I have seen about venturing patrols is when they're a part of a troop. do crews
divide into patrols within themselves and if not, how does a large crew of 30 or 40 function?
well, Jim, I think the answer is pretty is pretty easy. it might just be
switching terms around a little bit. well, the unit is called a venturing crew. there can be separate
crews within the unit. you're going to have it broken down into some kind of small groups.
I think the answer is asking the youth involved to define the way they want to organize themselves.
now I know in our venture crew what we find is is that that our youth members organize
themselves around activities rather than a set organizational structure. that's just kind of
constant. our venture crew forms into sub crews or less formal groups depending on what they're doing.
for example, we're going to Canada, go canoeing this summer, so the participants are divided into
two crews to train and prepare for that trip, and after the trip those crews will dissolve and
will reform for whatever the next activity is. so, Jim, I hope that helps. I heard from Kevin
Smith who said my son's Eagle border review is this Thursday and we wanted to know if the
border review date is the date that he's considered an eagle or if it's the date of his court of honor.
thanks for all your hard work. I pass your website and podcast on to every scouter I meet. well, thank
you, Kevin. this one's an easy answer. if we go to the guide to advancement in, are we ready?
everyone pencils up 8.0.1.5, titled after the review. if the members of the border review
agree a scout is ready to advance, he's called in and congratulated. the border review date, not
that of the subsequent court of honor, becomes the ranks effective date. this is true for all boards
of review, but in 8.0.3.0 there are some particulars for the eagle scout rank and, quoting the eagle
scout, metal or patch must not be sold or otherwise provided to any unit or to the scout.
nor should the court of honor be scheduled until after the certificate is received at
the council service center from the national advancement team. so let me be clear about this:
the border review date is the effective date of every rank, including eagle. but the only thing
particular about eagle: after the border review all the paperwork is going to be submitted
and until the certificates receive the council service center, you can't give the scout any
recognition and you don't schedule the court of honor until that certificate is taken care of.
because we know that as soon as the border review is over and as soon as we have the rank badges for
any other rank but eagle, we want to present them to the scout as soon as possible. as soon as
you get the certificate back from national with an eagle, you can get him a badge and you can
present it to him as soon as possible and then, like every other rank, you recognize them formally
at the court of honor. so Kevin wrote back and said: well, thanks, Clark, that's what I figured.
it's similar to any other rank advancement. I remember you had a podcast that stated: once a
border review is completed, the scout's entitled to wear the rank. well, that doesn't. you know
that doesn't. is that's not affected by the podcast, right? that's just kind of black and
white policy that that anybody can find in the guide to advancement. Kevin goes on to say:
after hearing that podcast, we bought it to the scouts who like the idea. rank advancement was
then awarded to the scouts at the next meeting and they are also recognized at the court of honor
and the scouts like that way much more. well, Kevin, I think it's great that you, uh the,
involve the scouts in that change and that that is not a negative thing to do at all. but
let me say this: this really isn't just some kind of optional way of doing things,
just clear policy, not my idea, it's just there in black and white in the guide to advancement
and I just want to say that that kind of policy stuff that's not subject to whether the
scouts like it or not, or whether you have a vote on it, or whether committee likes it or not.
it's right there. that's the way things work, so it really isn't a decision to be made or an
optional approach. it's pretty, you know. it's pretty much just hardwired into the program.
so if you have a question for me and you'd like to get in touch, it's pretty easy to do and
you're going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
well, thanks so much for listening to this 263rd edition of the scout master podcast.
here's how to keep in touch. read the blog at scoutmastercgcom and subscribe to receive updates
by email. join the 4,000 or so mobile scouts who have the scout master cg app on their mobile devices-
and you can get that at itunes or on google play. and remember we're all over social media, that's right.
join the 8500 folks that like scout master blog on facebook. tweet along with the chorus of 1200
tweeters on twitter. pin the poultry tuna's pictures properly, publicly, with 1900 other prolific
printers on pinterest. watch us at scout master cg on youtube, or join the 500 odd folks who form the
scout master cg circle on google plus now, if none of that appeals to you at all, if you'd rather not
face facebook, if twitter makes you better, if you've no interest in pinterest, if you don't put the you
in youtube, if you're a minus when it comes to google plus? google plus, what's that? well, it's kind
of like almost a social network that google started. so you know it's there, it's, it's actually still there.
then, anyways, if none of that works for you, you can zoom into the late 90s and send me an email.
you can get in touch with me at clark at scoutmastercgcom. c, l a, r, k, e at scoutmastercgcom.
did you know that none of this is sponsored by anybody or endorsed by anyone, especially people
like the boy scouts of america or any other scouting organization? no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
it's just me. that's right. i have a microphone and a laptop and a way to get online. unfortunately,
you would think somebody would be restricting access like this, but no, no, no. here i am and i'm
trying to help scout leaders and have a little bit of fun along the way. and speaking of fun,
here is our founder, sir robert bin. pal, sir robert. good luck to you and good camping.
well, thank you, sir, until next time everyone.